if that's your strategy for success the
only hit will show up in your mailbox is
not the check it's a freaking eviction
notice if you can't sell if you can't
influence if you can't persuade good
luck trying to get your business off the
ground and the only way to get from
conscious confidence to unconscious
competence is through practice some
people set goals and like behind but
they're crappy goals most people don't
have a compelling vision for their own
future you got to get honest don't blame
the boss don't blame the leaves don't
blame your job don't in the industry are
in my message this is only one way to
get rich and that's quick in the
internal world before you can master the
external world you have to master your
own internal world it's not how you
actually perform that earns you the
respect of your peers it's the fact that
you went out and actually did it I live
on love alone really go bring that to
the bank and pay the rent hello okay
he's an American author motivational
speaker and former stockbroker he
published a memoir the wolf of Wall
Street which was adapted into a feature
film the main subject line of his
seminars is what he calls the straight
line system he's Jordan Belfort and here
is top 10 rules for success I read this
book because I was in disbelief as
people here's the strategy for success
of the secret right go into your house
and do a quiet room and you close the
lights draw the shades and sit on a
couch and visualize a big fat check
twenty-five G's thousand bucks u.s. okay
with your name on it and I want you to
imagine that check and just make that
check go bigger in your mind and make it
real more real and just put it out into
the ether of the universe and the law of
attraction will take hold just think
about it oh right
hello if that's your strategy for
success the only hit will show up in
your mailbox is not the check it's a
freaking eviction notice from your
landlord
they'll be towing away your car your
wife your husband or the next door
neighbor and you'll be still saying
where's the check where's the check with
okay the secret is a load of crap
okay do I believe in manifestation yeah
damn straight I do but you got to take
action I'm one of those unfortunate
people I tried
I really do I tried it I read the books
well let me try you know so I said I'd
try to pray for the check never came but
I went out and started taking action
guess what the check came with extra a
couple of zeros and for like an
entrepreneur not a sales but how much
just an entrepreneur we're looking to
start a business well if you can't sell
if you can't influence you can't
persuade good luck trying to get your
business off the ground I'm not just
your customers I'm talking about the
bankers the people of venture
capitalists your vendors your credit
card processor the people who work for
you how do you get people to work for
you excited how'd you get them excited
to get into want to buy into your vision
at the highest level what sales really
is the transference of emotion and the
emotion you're transferring is this
emotion of certainty that don't feel
certain yet it's a good thing it's going
to help me it's gonna fill my need when
you're an entrepreneur you're trying to
start a business and you're recruiting
people while you're selling people on
your vision for the future your vision
for this company if you can't do that
good luck trying to get great people to
work for you
it's very it's almost it's nearly
impossible which is why we see you know
the people if they say oh he's a
visionary well that's true but typically
not only they visionaries they also
possess the ability to sell the vision
to other people to inspire them to
motivate them so selling is not just
like you know people think of selling oh
well a lot of salesmen I don't either
well yes you do you need to learn how to
influence how about trying to get your
kids to make their bed or do that
homework or believe in the value of
education how about trying to get a
landlord give you a reduction on your
rent or to extend the lease the way you
want have-nots trying to negotiate terms
you understand it cuts to everything so
I always looking to say you know when I
said crack the code on influence what I
really did essentially was I just I was
you know by working backwards almost by
saying under star at the end go to the
beginning say what has to happen before
someone says yes I was able to take that
and put it into the system that took the
no-name talentless skies and turn them
into millionaires there were four levels
of learning okay let me tell you what
the levels are some of you might know if
you've been through any self-development
this is some very basic stuff but it's
important here the first level is called
being unconsciously incompetent and what
that means is this when you first start
doing something you know so little about
it you basically
nothing you don't know what you don't
know this is a very scary spot to bid
when you're thrown into a situation and
you're a complete novice you said geez
I'd love to get better at this but I
haven't the slightest idea what I don't
know everyone follow that concept this
is what most people start off okay
the next level is becoming consciously
incompetent that means that you're like
Jesus Christ I don't know anything
you're like I've is this does that does
that song strategies they all sell great
I don't know them that's the next level
next level above that is called being
consciously competent consciously
confident means that you're good at
something but you can't really do it
with your eyes closed yet you're good
booth requires all your focus and your
mental energy like remember we were kids
growing up you'll need to tie your shoe
in the beginning you're like are you
sure like you putting your things across
and so with this excuse me like don't
interrupt me you can't tie your shoe and
have a conversation at the same time
right that's when you're consciously
competent is like it requires all your
conscious focus the next level above
that is called being unconscious
competence and that means when you're
really really great at something you can
do it without thinking about it and the
only way to get from conscious
competence to unconscious competence is
through practice there's no other way by
drilling it into your head again and
again and again and again and again
until your brain just clicks and all the
swords using the unconscious part of
your mind which is infinitely more
powerful than your conscious mind the
reason that most people are not
successful but not wealthy is not
because they set their goals too high
and miss them it's cause they set them
to go low and hit them yet that it's not
because you set your goals too high and
miss you set your goals too low and you
hit them and you get caught up in the
average day
the struggle of average ISM and
mediocrity that's what kills people
everybody raise your hand for a second
please
raise your hand now raise it as high as
you can I'm gonna crash so I can see
okay
now I'll just raise it a bit higher
everyone higher why the hell would that
happen
I say raise it as high as you can and
ham I said okay then a little I okay
well if you really mean it right you get
it it's that extra inch that's where you
want to set your goal not pie in the sky
and add a control like it's never going
to happen because that's a load of crap
to people that set those sort of goals
they abandon those goals and I'll get to
that later but the idea here is you want
to set the goals just above your comfort
zone so now think about it for a second
think about your goals right now how do
you set them you're setting them very
low and hitting them if that's the case
then give yourself a ten are you setting
goals that don't inspire you some people
set goals and left behind but they're
crappy goals they not the sort of goals
that make you jump out of bed in the
morning make you want to go to work for
yourself to secure the future not just
for you but for your family so you have
to compromise or acquiesce to anybody
unless you love them unless you want to
that's freedom you know money is just a
mechanism to get there you know most
people and here's the irony is that most
people don't have a compelling vision
for their own future they don't they
move through life setting goals and
goals have no power we're almost fear at
this point your goals on power 1959 when
Earl Nightingale came this idea of goal
setting and ever like wow I'm a goal
oriented person and that was great it
worked like 20 years everyone set goals
and they and they got results but then
all of a sudden you know you set goals
and sometimes you hit them sometimes you
know most times you don't okay that's
okay but goals almost became like a
synonym for like oh I'm gonna set a goal
who gives it really happens afterwards
and it almost is synonymous with failure
now goal-setting is something above and
I believe in setting goals but there's
got to be something above your goals and
that's your vision for the future and
it's not just about it doesn't have like
an ending points about the world being a
certain way and that's inspiring to you
and you when you truly have a vision for
your future that inspires you you're
going to jump up out of bed in the
morning and feel great about going at
life
versus being miserable and going to a
job you hate or living a life that
doesn't empower you and just you know
every day moving through just almost
like an automaton not really you know
having the zest and the great the
greatness of life and I'm joking I've
been there myself when I felt like I
didn't really have a compelling vision
for my own future and I felt like I was
wallowing but at least I'm conscious of
that once you become conscious of that
you can consciously create a vision for
your future it doesn't happen in once in
one minute or an hour you write it down
you work on until I mean you finally hit
on it you know you know you got it when
when you really fact yourself your
vision statement and it moves you and
you feel inspired okay and you know so
people have that and and what happens is
every human being is thirsty for a
vision everyone is and so few people
happen to what I do they gravitate
towards someone who has a vision for the
future they want to be a part of a
vision part of being a great
entrepreneur is having that vision be
able to create the vision and then sell
that vision to other people to get them
to want to be inspired to buy into it to
put in their time their hard work their
elbow grease to help you achieve your
vision if you're smaller then you spread
the wealth around it's a it's a win-win
for everybody the only thing that stops
you from getting what you want in life
is the bull story you tell yourself of
why you can't have it get that what
stops you back is the story because the
story stops you from getting honest and
if you can't get honest with yourself
there's no way you can go mad you like
the success in sales in life it's like a
road map right you know where you want
to go and you have this perfect strategy
the straight line to get there it's a
perfect strategy it's going to get you
there every single time but if you don't
know your starting point if you're not
getting eyes where you actually are it
doesn't matter how powerful the strategy
is and it doesn't matter how powerful
your goal is I'm gonna actually set a
goal today write a 60 day goal and let's
say you really set this goal and I'll
show you how to do it in a brilliant way
so it's visceral so it makes you really
feel it you see you sense it you smell
the goal that's step one I'm going to
teach you two straight line which is
your shrapp
to get to your goal but if you're not
honest with where you are right now your
starting point the math is worthless
there's three things that you need to
know where you are where you want to go
and how you're going to get there those
are the three things you must have to
take advantage of any opportunity I'm
gonna give you the strategy I'm going to
actually tell me exactly where you want
to go for yourself you got to get honest
don't blame the boss don't blame the
leads don't blame your job don't win the
industry or in just get honest you don't
like your industry find another one my
message is this there's only one way to
get rich and that's quick that's not a
get-rich-quick scheme though makes the
world's too expensive to get rich slowly
but what I mean by getting rich quick is
that there are certain things you have
to know on the inner game of wealth how
you manage your emotional state your
beliefs your standards your focus in the
outer game entrepreneurship sales
marketing how to develop multiple
streams of income once you it takes time
that's where the hard work is a lot of
hard work goes into getting this lined
up and that lined up but once you have
it all lined up have you've done the
work then you can make money very very
quickly so it's not a scheme but you got
to get rich quick and you have to put
the work in I say if you don't wanna
work hard good luck I mean I don't know
any rich people it don't work really
really all right that's the bottom line
so hard work and knowing knowing stuff
skills there's no quick fix see though
it's that you know it's again when you
get rich it happens quickly but there's
a lot of work that goes up to that point
before the money starts pouring and
that's the distinction that I think a
lot of people who are not wealthy they
don't get that they think that it's you
accumulate money's a little bit at a
time it doesn't work that way you work
work work don't get the resultant BAM
one last piece of the puzzle clicks in
whether it's not knowing how to close in
all happens quickly also to really take
a longer-term view not just you know to
look three months from now but look
three years now and but the future is
going to come whether you like it or not
so you want to kind of be one step ahead
it's a mind game then it's why I think
it's psychology and everything again
life most of life comes down to
psychology doesn't it it starts here in
the internal world before you can master
the external world you have
the master your own internal world
that's the true secret to success my
sons 14 is fabulous and we're having
this conversation about when he plays in
sports or when he does something about
you go full out or do you not and I see
sometimes in him that when he's out on
the field of doing something he doesn't
play full out and I'll have an excuse
like my leg hurts or my arm hurts or
something happened the coach was unfair
what are the angle the referee was
unfair and what happens with people is
we tend to go out into the world and we
look for those sort of excuses about why
things aren't the way we want them and
when you do that you lose all your power
in life when you start focusing on the
external on the excuses you lose your
power here is the way people really
think I will tell you I can go out on
the stage and bomb you go out there you
just bomb right and people will respect
you for going out there and trying your
hardest it's not how you actually
perform that earns you the respect of
your peers it's the fact that you went
out and actually did it that's the
difference so if you're out there right
now you're a new salesperson or you're
struggling as a salesperson there's no
embarrassment in struggle that's just
not the embarrassment is in quitting the
embarrassment is it not trying your
hardest poor people believe they are
creatures of circumstance that means
that the life life happens to them you
get that wall rich people are creators
of circumstance I will tell you this
there is no more destructive belief in
the world and to think that life happens
to you because there's three things that
you do when you don't think that you can
create your own destiny I'll tell you
exactly what they are right number one
the first thing you do is you play what
I call the blame game you stop blaming
everybody for why you don't have what
you want you'll blame the government
you'll grin your family you blame your
spouse you'll blame your boss
you'll blame the economy you'll blame
the people on Wall Street which probably
deserve some blame but you'll blame
anybody in everybody when you think the
world happens to you you're powerless
the second thing you do is you justify
it is because because the economy's
thinks it's because people are unfair to
me it's because money doesn't really
matter anyway
[ __ ] you all know that I live on
love alone really go bring that to the
bank and pay the rent hello okay I love
LA middle all other the greatest woman
in the world on them I'm gonna get
married next year for the third time
unfortunately I'm getting married next
year great woman so I know that but you
know money's money right they justify
third this is the worst one of all so
write it down in big lives they complain
I hate these people you know why I'll
tell you why because I do believe in
some laws of the universe
I do and one of them is that what you
focus on expands gets bigger and what
you focus on you attract because you
move towards it
your focus is on you attract so here's
what happens when you're complaining
what are you focusing on all the in your
life so guess what happens to you you
become a giant magnet get the picture I
don't want to be around because they
attracted to you got to get away from
them because when you're some playing
like that you too and it's the worst of
all that's what complaining does so if
you're a person that believes that you
know you're a creature of circumstance
life happens to you good luck thank you
guys so much for watching we made this
video because Vlad Vasily have asked us
to if you have a famous entrepreneur or
a very special person you'd like this
guy to make a video of leave it in the
comments below I'd also love to know
which of the top 10 rules you heard
today meant the most to you leave in the
comments with joining the discussion
thank you so much for watching continue
to
leave and we'll see you see mm-hmm we
will